the soundtrack from the passion hit
number one on iTunes Netflix is rushing
to showed a stream on Friday and only
leaves but with Trisha Yearwood today
about her emotional performance she had
the audience in New Orleans in tears
including our biggest fan of all the
love of her life if I could tell just
one thing usually when I go and do
something on my own
I don't drag Garth Brooks with me
because it's like well here's my husband
you know I don't make him go oh but for
this I said I really need you there and
if I say I need you there he's gonna be
there it was incredibly powerful to
happen
Tricia felt some serious pressure
playing Mary the mother of Jesus while
some of the show was pre-tape she had to
sing her five songs like it was powerful
I mean it was kind of we're all in this
together and when when it hit live TV
everybody cheered and it was like okay
we're in it Garth was overcome by the
emotion of it all he cried during the
whole thing he just said I'm really
proud of you if he loved it I will get
down on my knees it's so many things
that he brings to the table for me there
is definitely a support and a calming
there's also a he's watching so I want
to impress him you know we've been here
10 years I still want to impress the guy
so it's like you know I it makes me up
my game when he's in the room because I
want I want him to go wow I mean because
I want to impress a mic you know flirtin
with